had to get life insurance so I'm talking
to the lady she's asking me all the
question how old are you do you smoke do
you drink and I was like no no no not
really one one or two cocktails a week
you know I only have a podcast called we
might be drunk and I have a drinking
problem whatever I'm hung over right now
but two drinks a week so she goes all
right sounds great this is this is going
to be a breeze we'll get this we'll get
this cooking and I go great 2 Days Later
how much weed are we talking way no
barely any how does weed affect your
life what yeah weed's no good that's
crazy I know does Snoop Dog not have
life insurance like it's doctors tell
you to smoke week she's like what about
any other drugs I go I don't do any
drugs and she's like all right somehow
they saw protect our parks and we're
eating mushrooms like a like a like a
seal ran throw them in our mouth I got
denied yeah obviously if they s protect
our par like these guys are dead not
chugging whiskey we're drinking out of
an eagle's ass we're beer bonging